Algorithmic bias, like human
bias, results inunfairness.
However, algorithms, like viruses,
can spread bias on a massive scale
at arapid pace.
Algorithmic bias can also lead
to exclusionary experiences
and discriminatorypractices.
So what can we do about it?
Well, we can start thinking about
how we createmore inclusive code
and employ inclusive coding practices.
It really starts with people.
Sowho codes matters.
Are we creating full-spectrum teams
with diverse individuals
who can checkeach other's blind spots?
How we code matters.
Are we factoring in fairness as
we're developingsystems?
And finally, why we code matters.
We've used tools of computational creation
to unlockimmense wealth.
We now have the opportunity to
unlock even greater equality
if we make socialchange a priority
and not an afterthought.